mell be scary spices in the news
speaking of drinking she's in the news
she had a horrible accident she fell
down some stairs broke her ribs and she
claimed severed her hand I don't think
she knows what the word severed means
did she literally cut her hand off I
think she just cut it anyway she ended
up in the hospital and she was visited
by the other members of her band who
were need her to make money so they were
very eager to make sure that she's
staying healthy were they all there not
all of them no there was one missing
prissy spice or whatever spice pissy
spice snooty spice posh posh Victoria
Beckham did not show up
no visiting people in the hospital she's
like I'm better than these girls I'm
married to a soccer player
oh sorry football now Bend It Like
Beckham she says that she was asleep in
an upstairs bedroom of her friends when
she decided to go downstairs and when
fell down a narrow staircase yeah I fell
him down some narrow staircase she's has
a history of substance abuse but she and
her lawyer claimed they were not
involved in this accident it was just an
accident sometimes you just stumble down
the stairs in the dark sometimes you do
fair enough you know it's something
similar happened to me last night I was
staying in a hotel
completely unfamiliar place and
sometimes the middle of the night you
wake up and look alright take a [ __ ]
whiz right and I don't turn the lights
on and [ __ ] I just kind of used like
that radar sense and the sound of the
piss hitting the water and I'm like
alright I'm clothed daredevil yes yes I
like to
that might wake me up and [ __ ] like that
and said you know I share space with
somebody else that might wake her up I
was by myself to be fair but I'm just so
trained to do it on the dark also this
is true and a little confession I'm
going to bring the show down but heavy
most of my life until fairly recently
and I'm still not [ __ ] thin per se
but like I was much heavier and I never
like to see reflections myself like a
[ __ ] vampire so I left the lights on
at all time and I'm just trained to do
that last night when I got up went to
take a piss man I was like oh [ __ ] I
think I'm hitting it yeah I'm hitting it
I'm sure I'm hitting it in the morning I
got up went to take a piss again it was
like whooped and slipped in a puddle of
my own piss I'd missed the toilet
[ __ ] completely completely man and I
was like why don't you turn the lights
on and [ __ ] anyway back to you I'm just
saying it's possible I'm guessing scary
spice did not slip on the steps in a
puddle of her own urine I'm guessing
that's not the circumstances by the way
how much do you tip when you leave a
hotel room for the housekeeping staff
that has to come in like 20 bucks but to
be fair I did mop it up myself with the
tank and then I put the towel into the
tub and I took a shower so it kind of
rinse the towel I mean this is way too
much [ __ ] detail my point was I
pissed on the [ __ ] floor I got it I
think we are so [ __ ] up that I pissed
on the [ __ ] floor and [ __ ] like I
wasn't [ __ ] high or drunk I think he
was we understand news I had no right
for us and you were just you know the
purple gaze is my dick is smaller than I
think it is like I think it's longer so
I'm like no I'm clearly I'm hitting the
bowl but it's up here and it's just
shooting out into the sky and [ __ ] like
that what I got to do is turn the light
on and push my dick down that makes more
sense
[Music]
you
[Music]